[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente de france
24 yo soy maría clara calle es la década
de la encrucijada ambiental si la
humanidad no reduce a la mitad las
emisiones de carbono para el año 2030 es
casi inevitable que el planeta se
caliente más de 15 grados celsius
respecto a los niveles preindustriales
así lo advirtió el panel
intergubernamental sobre el cambio
climático en su más reciente informe el
tercero de cuatro con los que harán la
evaluación del calentamiento global este
grupo de expertos explica además que si
las políticas ambientales no mejoran las
temperaturas podrían subir más de 3,2
grados celsius por eso insisten en que
es el momento de actuar ahora o nunca
ante este panorama el reporte habla de
cómo mitigar el impacto del cambio
climático para entender las soluciones
propuestas hablamos con maría virginia
vilariño una de las autoras líderes del
informe del ipcc ella nos precisó que
falta que la tecnología se distribuya en
todos los países y que también son
necesarias decisiones financieras y
políticas en la mayoría de los sectores
las soluciones de energías renovables o
energías más limpias y eficiencia
energética eficiencia en el uso de
recursos esas energías existen y están
hoy aplicadas y digamos de manera
bastante amplia en muchos países el
problema es que tiene que llegar a todos
los países y a todos los sectores es muy
poco tiempo y por ello es van a poder
ver que el reporte hace mucho énfasis en
lo que le llaman las condiciones
necesarias para acelerar esta transición
y van más allá de tecnología hablamos
fundamentalmente de la de las
condiciones financieras de políticas
necesarias políticas inteligentes que
hacen falta
y del acceso a esta financiación y a la
tecnología de los países menos en esa
búsqueda de soluciones el ips se
discutió uno de los temas más polémicos
los combustibles fósiles responsables de
cerca del 70% de las emisiones
contaminantes los científicos sostienen
que capturar y eliminar carbono es
esencial para lograr un equilibrio entre
la cantidad de co2 que se produce y la
que puede aguantar el planeta y hay dos
maneras de absorción la natural y otra
con tecnología como nos lo explico
vilariño foco sobre todo costos en las
opciones biológicas en los métodos
biológicos naturales de
remover y secuestrar carbono como son la
reforestación el manejo adecuado de los
suelos la conservación de humedales de
todos los ecosistemas que son ricos en
captura carbón es que ese es el stock
que tenemos que mantener ahí otra otra
discusión mucho más el ejemplo
tecnológico del punto de vista de
políticas necesarias y sobre todo el
punto está de aceptación social
se aplica a las tecnologías de captura
directa no naturales de captura directa
de deseo de la atmósfera y
este desde el punto vista económico como
decía sobre todo es cosa social están en
un escalón de alguna manera inferior a
la de los métodos biológicos naturales
pero por más co2 que se elimine se
necesita frenar el carbón el gas y el
petróleo y ahí estuvo la gran discusión
en su reporte de 3.000 páginas los
científicos reiteraron que las políticas
públicas son más efectivas cuando
incluyen la eliminación gradual de esas
energías pero en el resumen para quienes
toman las decisiones políticas no se
habló de eliminar los combustibles
fósiles y es que en esta última sesión
sólo participaron los coordinadores de
cada capítulo y los representantes de
los 193 gobiernos de la onu es decir si
los expertos por eso la redacción es
diferente de hecho la fase final del
debate fue tan discutida que el ipcc
cambió la hora de publicación del
reporte originalmente era
m hora de londres y terminaron por
lanzarlo a las 4 pm
sin embargo en el informe total se
mantuvo la palabra eliminación contrario
a lo que pasó en la cob 26 cuando se
habló de reducción vilariño nos explicó
que esto se debe a que el ipcc es un
órgano científico que analiza todo el
conocimiento que está disponible
mientras que la convención marco de la
onu para cambio climático o la cob está
ligada con la política una cosa es la
recomendación técnica y lo que la
ciencia dice que deberíamos hacer para
lograr los objetivos climáticos el
acuerdo de parís establece y otra es
basado en este conocimiento científico
lo que logran negociar con la componente
política los países en la convención
marco de naciones unidas y el riesgo de
no limitar los combustibles fósiles es
enorme porque la contaminación aumentará
y que el planeta se caliente tres grados
celsius más no es sólo sentir más calor
en los veranos sino que aumenta hasta
mil veces la pérdida de especies puede
incrementar las enfermedades e incluso
amenazar la producción de alimentos y
los suministros de energía como nos lo
precisó maría virginia vilariño
este aumento de temperatura pondría en
jaque pondré en compromiso la capacidad
de producir alimentos en cantidad y
calidad en la gran parte de las regiones
del mundo puede alguna región en
particular y experimentar digamos una
especie de condiciones favorables por un
tiempo corto pero al final la ecuación
es negativa para la producción de
alimentos y la calidad de esos alimentos
en todo el mundo como como un sistema
importantísimo y básico a nivel de los
sistemas energéticos también sabemos que
se verían afectados sobre todo aquellos
países que tienen su materia energética
es muy dependiente de el agua de la
disputa de la disponía de abono porque
la falta de disponía de agua pondría en
jaque también la producción de energía
hidroeléctrica que al menos en muchas
regiones como latinoamérica es la
predominante
pero también pondría en jaque el sistema
energético en general porque debería
este sistema que provee este energía y
confort a todos los sociedades adaptarse
a cambios en la demanda en lugares donde
antes quizás la demanda de refrigeración
era muy baja va a ser muy alta y los
sistemas estos porque no van a estar en
condiciones de responder esos picos de
mann como hasta aquí la crónica de medio
ambiente vean esta y más emisiones en
france 24 punto com hasta la próxima
[Música]